i want to talk about uh your honor which
i i
i love this show oh good and um
i actually uh got very wrapped up in it
it's a
fantastic idea for show and one of my
favorite things about the show
is how um your character
this this judge is a very decent uh
you know um is very decent person with a
very strong moral code
who has to make these decisions to save
his son
and so every step of the way i
understand why are characters doing
what they're doing and at the same time
these are decisions which are go against
everything that you believe is right
that's what got me hooked on this show
to do it in the first place was that
premise of
if you really thought your child was in
danger of being killed what would you do
right to protect him or her in
anything everything and i talked to any
parent and they said
yeah i would become a criminal i would
and that my character is a superior
court judge and he does
he lies to authorities which is a crime
he
destroys evidence he creates alibis he
manipulates juries
he's doing whatever he can to keep his
son alive and
each step it's going so against his
principles that it's eroding his soul
it keeps going deeper and deeper and
deeper
and i also love that it takes place in
new orleans which
to me i would want to if i was ever
involved in some showbiz venture and
they said
pick a city where it's going to happen i
might choose new orleans
just for the food alone yeah you know
that's not going to happen for you
that's i mean
you don't think they're not going to say
be involved in an
entertainment program of some sort i
don't think
i think you've shot your wad here
i think i'm doing really well brian
thank you
right i talk till i'm blue in the face
how has it been for you all these years
my friend
where you have to you have to walk that
line between
being supportive and being sycophantic
you don't like to
be an ass kisser but you you have to you
have to support him but
have you ever really just come out and
told the truth about a monologue that he
did and said that was terrible
uh no i just i just general
not specifically i just generally keep
him frightened of me
oh yeah yeah yeah andy early on
um sort of intimated that he had a very
violent temper
and he's also physically one of the
strongest people i've ever met
so the first thing i do to every day at
work is i come in and i have a pumpkin
and i crush it in my hands
and then we're fine yeah wow so i don't
mess with andy
also i will say in andy's defense after
all these years of working together he
does not lie
i've never seen him laugh at something
genuinely laugh at something
that he didn't think uh is funny and you
can go back and look at thousands and
thousands of hours of late night shows
plenty of times he is not laughing
that yeah that there have been people
who have pointed that out yeah
yeah like after after a segment and gone
like man you weren't much help but i'm
like
yeah yeah yeah and it's so funny because
if we have someone great and funny
if a brian cranston's on andy's in there
he's yucking it up he's coming up with
great things
when i've had people on that are giving
me nothing andy
leans back crosses his legs and just
says
you're it's your plane and it's going
down good luck to you
and afterwards i'll be like what the
hell and he's like hey you know what do
you want me to do
get my get my hands dirty trying to help
you and that's it
he
yeah yeah that that came to an end yeah
that's i understand that
now i do you know i know that you think
it's unlikely that i will become
a serious actor of great renown uh but
i did mean what i said i would want to
be in new orleans
are you eating the food because i see
there there was one episode i saw we
were having this giant shrimp dinner and
it looks fantastic and i'm thinking are
you eating that food are you one of
those actors that pretends
i always eat the food that's get on a
set
even when i'm not supposed to i'm uh i
that's always been a pet peeve of mine
to see a scene
at a thanksgiving dinner or something
and and people are kind of pushing
around the
food and no one's really eating and
everybody's like ha ha ha
i was like i don't believe that yeah i
mean part of
part of creating a dramatic
interpretation
of a scenario is to to be as real as
possible eat the food
and so you'll see me chowing down that
was real shrimp yes
and we were dipping in the sauce
somewhere's hotter than others
your eyes are watering it was it was
great
that's one of my pet peeves uh about uh
john cryer who i love i love john cry
who doesn't love john cryer
love that guy uh and i think he's
hilarious and a terrific actor
two and a half men anytime that shows on
and he's eating i noticed he's just
pushing the food
and pushing it around and i john cryer
eat the food
eat the food when you're doing a scene
that show's gonna go nowhere
[Applause]
my prediction now what is your uh okay
so you eat the food what about love
scenes
what's your technique in life eat the
food and love scenes
[Laughter]
i've noticed that whenever you have a
sex scene and throughout your career
uh you're always you've got food on the
nightstand
food and you're taking a lot of breaks
to eat oh yeah food whipped cream
strawberries yeah yeah
i want to be authentic so i have to go
to my partner
and say we really have to have sex
or we're liars or we are just
charlatans
and how's that go over i've several
lawsuits which i can't talk about
i've still got my fingers crossed it's
going to work someday uh-huh yeah
[Laughter]
you know i very much i'm a fan of the
show your honor and
uh very happy for you that uh it is
such an excellent show um and i wanted
to show a clip
from the show and then it turns out well
here's the problem because it it's
it's behind it's apparently i'm not
allowed to show a clip
why i we we went to get a clip they said
we can't release a clip to you
i said it's me conan o'brien oh is that
that
anyone but conan answer that is that the
thing
i hate hearing that i actually did try
to we tried to get a clip my producer
called me and he said
no they won't release a clip from your
honor it's this new world we live in
a paywall i suppose something's going on
uh
i don't know what it is so if we we have
to show some clip
okay so here we go
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my god those are intense eyes and
michael vincent
yeah and i think this show again was on
for seven
years i think it was something like that
um
yeah no but you know it's funny because
uh
i talked to you recently uh and and it
was so clear to me when i was talking to
you that one of the things you're
proudest of
is that you have been for for many many
years this
journeyman actor you have made your
living as an actor and
i think people just focus on oh my god
there's this massive hit breaking bad
and it's this
iconic worldwide phenomenon and what
they forget is all the years
where you were bad guy number two in
uh in in a show that ran in the 80s that
most people are not even thinking about
anymore and that that
is a big part of the trade for people
that get into acting
that that is it and you're lucky to get
that the transition in that show you're
you're talking about i was i was very
fortunate because i was
cast as bad guy number three and
i was promoted to back guy number two
uh what is true is that for an actor the
you get those hotel clerk busboy drunken
frat boy
all those guys and when you finally get
a name
it's like oh god i'm daryl i'm
daryl you know you're so excited if you
get a last name you've made it
you have you have made it remember the
last name
i am we've made it very clear i am not
an actor and never should be an actor
but early on when i first got out to la
like in 85
86 um someone saw me
somewhere being amusing and they said oh
i recommended you to a casting agent for
a jim henson
show with not puppets but
with uh you know uh live performers and
i remember that i
knew nothing about it and they sent me
the sides the script
and um the script they sent me had two
characters in it
and they didn't tell me which character
i was supposed to audition for
and i was confused and i said can you
send me the script
can you send me anything more so they
just sent me a sheet that described what
each character
was and the first one was dirk every man
wants to be him every woman wants to be
with him and i remember going like
it's not dirk and then and then the
second one was like
you know gormley and it was like gormley
he's as goofy as he is nerdy he's he's a
really
skinny doofus who's never once who's
never lost his virginity and i was like
it's this guy sure enough i show up and
they're like oh how'd you know
i once got set a script and the part
that they
wanted me to read within the text of the
script was
like say the guy's name was jerry jerry
comma
32 a complete piece of [ __ ]
and we thought of you
so what part of a big piece of [ __ ] made
you think about me
yeah we can't just give you the role
you understand because there are other
pieces of [ __ ]
in town that are pretty damn stinky i
would see the same pieces of [ __ ] in
every waiting room in town
every time you show up three other
pieces of [ __ ] are there
hey [ __ ] ball hey [ __ ] for brains hey